been some dissatisfaction with the
government and people have been
frustrated I think here in Medway there
are some local issues as well for
example we've been hit with unrealistic
housing Targets in my constituency so
we're having to build really significant
numbers of homes there's uproar against
that from the local community
and you know people want to see us
building for the local need but not for
for everyone else at the end of the day
we've been in government 13 years we
know that people have been upset with
with the government absolutely there be
people who are who may be voting because
they're dissatisfied with us